hello guys
i'm ryan wright and i'm lisa mahelick
lisa
her first time on the real rejects i
noticed lisa is white
dude i noticed many things about you and
one of them was you're white
we're going to check out it's from z
flow network he did the black people
song now
i have a white person with me to do the
white people
song all right lisa i'm half white
okay a lot of people don't realize that
half italian
half filipino it works on you it does
work on me i think i'm a very you're
looking good
i think i got a like a strikingly
handsome thing you know if i just lost a
little bit more weight i'd be gorgeous
oh whatever
not whatever it's a fact okay my bad
just like the black people song the [ __ ]
okay whatever
this song is dedicated to a certain kind
of people
which just so happens to be my
other favorite kind of people you know
the ones that like to
you know hurt themselves bro skateboard
ollie bro
kick flip slit your lip bro kick me in
the nuts bro
you get what i'm saying right white
people i get
bullied in school i can't wait till i'm
a cop so i can
bully you white whoa
who's a bad michael go to your room
michael
if you poke me on my arm i bruise easily
so i only quarterback
in the football league i like to watch
porn i can fap for days and my favorite
potato chips are lays because they're
white
i take weird drugs like ecstasy
mushrooms crystal meth
and lsb we put it in a pipe for a
homemade bong and watch out for the
priest he will rape your son
and most of us would die trying out for
fear factor
i guess that's why they say i'm just a
country loving deer hunting rabbit
eating redneck
inbreeding beer drinking small penis did
i mention we drive a tractor
i guess my point here is if you're white
we
automatically like you white people
i get bullied in school i can't wait
till i'm a cop so i can
bully you white people such a [ __ ] up
lie
hey
seriously all of us are racist all right
so this is probably also the most racist
song i've written
but if you laugh you're racist too
because i don't feel bad
besides it's not racist if i'm human
you get it the human race that's how
white people laugh
okay all right okay all right
how do you feel are you offended there
are some definitely inaccurate things i
feel like
such as no butt are you serious
okay i gotta say i have a butt lisa has
a butt i have a
it's a big one it's what everyone talks
about in class
is it that's what everyone says when she
walks away
not even in like oh damn check out that
ass it's just like a fact like
it's just so there it's there and i'm
white i'm extremely white there's just
no getting past that
clearly don't you have to like work to
get a butt like that i feel like
like black people tend to just have a
natural
yeah they were born that way yeah do you
don't you have to like
because you you do like figure skating
and crossfit and yeah
so i do my squats i won't lie but i have
a butt regardless
regardless yes yeah what do you don't
know how much i can
engage in this particular conversation
boundaries i don't know i mean i feel
like this guy
has access to like it's not even the
song it's like okay whatever you know i
feel like we're way more used to white
people getting insulted and it being
okay yeah
because it's like whatever they still
have privileges in the universe
something like that
i didn't struggle with it but the idea
of someone might see someone who's white
and just perceive
that like hey you're you're all these
things that are talked about in the
video
yeah it's sad because i see that more
often than usual like someone will see
someone who's white and then
they'll assume that oh probably wasn't
that bad white people
there's so many jokes about it it's the
same thing with like women jokes or
blonde jokes or
you know they have the black people song
too they hear it all the time and so
people are just like yeah well it's
funny they'll be fine
i know the guy's making fun of the
stereotypes and cliches but i'm like
that's all the song really is is
stereotypes and cliches and i
i feel like you could be more creative
with it he could really get something
because i'm like you got all this
awesome animation and i feel like you're
limiting yourself on the lyrical point
though yeah it was catchy but
it's catchy it's the same team as the
black people song the whole [ __ ] line
about like
that was bad you want to be bullied and
you grow up to
be a cop who's gonna like bully black
people yeah that was
okay that wasn't right that was too that
um that was crossing the line
now the black people song i thought was
funny i did too
i'm half white that offends me not cool
with it
not cool with it weird how when it's
someone else's race i
can see like the perception of humor a
lot better but when it's
you're saying you're not cool with this
one because you're half white yeah
got it like it attacks my ego yeah i was
taking a lot of things personally i was
like trying to relate to it
you start feeling like you stand for
something
potato chips come on good chips
now that they're white maybe a little
bit a little bit a little bit there's a
little bit of white
white everyone has pride in their
culture why can't white people laugh
right in there
yeah it's like the weirdest thing i see
i feel like white people are the ones
who
who get like they're they're not allowed
to be prideful of themselves
no they gotta reel it in yeah you gotta
reel it in embrace yourself
you're white you're white i'm half white
and uh white
it's a good suit for me yeah like i said
it looks good on you
thanks lisa it's a great combo thanks
ryan right but there's some funny lines
in there
like when he's talking about how like
why people bruise easily
and then how they're like the only
quarterback in the nfl
yeah cause everyone else is black
because that's what he's implying yeah
that's kind of funny it's kind of clever
it's true
why people bruise easily we do i mean
we do i don't i i'm pretty tanned yeah
half asian that's another thing i don't
tan i can't tan you just turn red
very red did he cover that in this
totally he didn't even say that he
didn't talk about sunburns and freckles
yeah that's like a thing i know a lot of
why people have a hard time
with yeah oh sunburn's the worst it is
the worst you are pretty
white i am you're liking my you're like
white
i like i i don't get how you need
sunglasses to look at me
i'm saying like your skin color looks
white i don't know
well my dad always told me when we were
on vacation i would try to go out and
try to tan and be cool
i would come back in i'd be super red
like a lobster he would be like lisa
there's some people that can tan and he
would look at me and say oh
and there are some people that can't and
guess which one you are
and it's true i was a lobster and it
didn't look right
it wasn't cool nothing was cute about it
no i embraced the pace now embrace
the pace did you intend to make that
kind of run
um yeah i did good for you slogan good
for you
thank you is that another white person
thing
uh bad rhymes
sort of bad rhymes there's a lot of
cliches i feel like that could have been
included in here
yeah one of them is you know when white
people try to act black
yes it's like just try try it right
for one second do what white people do
when they try to act black
girl you going out to the club tonight
yeah
we're gonna go to the club you know
nails did first yeah that's all i got
right now that's all you got
i mean i got more but that's all yeah
that's that's all i should do because
i'm not good at it but no
that's what that's what the thing is
that's the thing is why people are not
good at it like you try to fit in
sometimes they think they are
you know like i'm fortunate to have i
think i have like a johnny depp thing
going on you know where you're like what
the [ __ ] race is he
i like that that is cool i often compare
myself to johnny depp and he does
but he does a good impression i must say
thank you hey wait they also
said white people can't dance is this
true do you
do you dance i get down do you
how do you get this are you like i mean
i will dance to nothing
there'll be no song on and you'll see me
just like i'll be eating a good pizza
and i'll just be like yes
like any of my friends who know me and
see me eat
all right well i i just i love to dance
and yeah
maybe i'm a goofy dancer but i still
dance they said we can't
dance i i feel like he was like
primarily attacking like
southern states and like yeah
like i'm like what encounter i feel like
where i live like the vicinity and the
miles that stretch yeah i i don't feel
like the white people are like this
i don't think so yeah i don't think so
at all this is [ __ ] up dude this is
messed up
you know what the worst part is you're
not even white so you can't
say all this [ __ ] that's so true
such a such a rev roll reversal that's
what we just did there
well anyways eat flow network you still
made for an entertaining thought process
there
so i appreciate that go check out his
channel
because he clearly puts in a lot more
work than i do i mean that takes time
that took a lot of effort and thought
this video video's gonna take like an
hour
to add an hour and a half yeah i'm a
hard worker
you are own it own that
that's how what's how white people feel
this is how we embrace it this is how we
own it
yeah anyway guys listen my name is ryan
wright this is the channel called the
real rejects
why don't you subscribe come reject
today
that's right naming fans such a
cool youtuber thing to do lisa
what's your last name lisa mahele helen
mel hallick mahelick you're not jewish
no i'm not mel halleck mahalik feel that
rule
the hell the uh she has a
instagram right yes what what is it on
instagram
it's lisa m mahalik there's a text right
here for you guys
oh to be able to see how it's spelled
she has wonderful photos on there
if i can remember what's on there they
were good photos
thank you i appreciate that i approve
of what you did because you know it's
like
you're blonde you're good looking you
could have easily went for the whole
like
bikini thing which she doesn't she
doesn't
sorry sorry about it
i shouldn't wait if she is
that instagram i'm from chicago so we
didn't have a lot of classy
to be she's like zucchini ready you know
if i recall i mean thank you i'm classy
she's classy that's the thing you don't
get too many class out here in l.a
bunch of [ __ ] every now and then i'm
joking
most of you are not [ __ ] most